- I am gonna go out on a limb and say
that this is better to
dunk Oreos in than milk,
that orange juice is better than milk.
I said it.
It's on the internet.
(uptempo music)
- I just don't know why.
- I like how it looks.
It just looks appealing,
so you know, it doesn't
really gross you out
until you say, "Oh, it's mayonnaise."
- I think it's gonna be really terrible
and it's gonna taste like crap.
- I'm actually very excited about this
because I think it's
gonna taste really good.
- Um, okay.
- It's okay.
Um, the mouth feel was
weird, not gonna lie.
- Oh, no.
- I like it.
- I'm fine with it.
- It makes it taste like cream cheese.
- Oh my god, I actually hate it.
- This is sick.
- It tastes worse than I thought it would.
- Way better than I expected.
I like mayonnaise now apparently.
- Conceptually, I'm not against this.
Also, I feel like apples go in salads.
Like, people put apples in salads
and you put pepper and
salt on it, so I'm--
- I'm not opposed to this one.
- I think I'll like it.
- Cheers.
- Cheers, mate.
- Mm.
- Okay, I'm really into this.
Superior apple eating experience.
- Yeah, this is really good.
- This is so much better than
eating just a plain apple.
- Mm.
- I don't like that.
- This is actually pretty decent.
This tastes like a fancy appetizer.
- I feel like it just like,
covered my whole tongue
with a lot of flavor, and like,
none of them were
complementary to each other.
- It enhances the flavor a lot more.
- Totally.
- Oh my god.
This is surprisingly really good.
- I know.
- I love it.
- I would not have thought
to put salt and pepper
on apple slices before, but
it's actually really good.
- No.
- Absolutely not.
- Please take it away.
- I'm excited 'cause I love OJ
and I'm always eating Oreos.
- No thank you.
- I'm gonna say no.
- At first glance, I'm taken aback,
but thinking about it, like,
chocolate and orange
is absolutely a thing,
and then there's like,
cream in the cookies,
and you've got like a
creamsicle situation here.
- There you go.
- I will do this in the name of content.
Oh, this is great.
- It's not bad, it's not bad.
- Yeah, I like this.
- It's not that bad.
It doesn't really coat
the cookie that much.
- Is it weird to say like,
I feel like I like this more than milk?
- I was the one who was
skeptical about this,
but I actually kind of really like it.
- Oh no!
- Okay, this is really interesting
because I really like Flamin' Hot Cheetos.
- Hmm.
- I feel like at least
this is gonna cool down
the heat of the hot flaming Cheetos,
but I think it's gonna be disgusting.
- Part of what makes Cheetos
so good is they're crunchy.
- I'm looking forward to trying it.
- I think it might be surprisingly good,
but it just, it's just scary.
- I'm literally tearing right now.
I'm not looking forward to eating this.
- It made it cold.
I'm eating a cold Cheeto.
Put it in your freezer.
- It literally numbed all the fieriness.
- It actually tastes like cereal,
like spicy cereal, so it's not bad.
- Yeah, it's not bad.
- If you're eating Flamin' Hot Cheetos,
you gotta commit to it.
You don't need to put
training wheels on them.
- If you wanna dump these in milk,
get plain ass Cheetos.
- A million percent.
- Well, you know, I
feel like I'm still open
to trying anything at least once.
- I'd like to try more.
- Not against it.
- I think I need to open up
my fridge a little bit more.
- I mean, some things
sound really gross to me
but at least I gave it a chance.
- The fact this is happening
on camera kind of shocks me,
but like, I've never had
Flamin' Hot Cheetos before.
(uptempo music)